llegamos aquí
[Música]
y una experiencia inmersiva en la triple
hélice de desarrollo
días atrás
cuando estaba pensando en cómo
introducir el concepto de triple hélice
como modelo de desarrollo revisé papers
libros revistas artículos
y en esa revisión recordé que hace algún
tiempo había posteado algo acerca de la
triple hélice de desarrollo
así que me metí en mi red social fui al
twitter empecé a regresar a realizar a
realizar en el tiempo y encontré esto
justamente hoy hace un año y cuatro días
escribí acerca de la de la triple hélice
de desarrollo y decía que estos tres
sectores el sector industrial el sector
académico y el sector empresarial son
fundamentales son fundamentales para
impulsar la innovación compartir también
un documento que me ha servido cuando he
tenido que hacer política pública me ha
servido con fuente de consulta cuando
tengo que discutirlo con mis estudiantes
en la universidad y me han servido
también como fuente de consulta cuando
tengo que desarrollar proyectos
empresariales sin embargo en esa ocasión
recibí un comentario que ustedes pueden
ver ahí eso ya sabemos algún caso de
éxito y ecuador- eso ya sabemos
entonces me preocupo un poco ese
comentario pero ahora que lo estaba
revisando para preparar esta
presentación me preocupo aún más
y me generó al menos tres preguntas
realmente ya sabemos que el sector
productivo academia y sector
y empresarial del ecuador
son los sectores que articulados e
interactuando impulsan la innovación
realmente estamos conscientes de eso
segunda pregunta dado que estos tres
sectores la academia
el sector público y el sector privado
que incluye el sector productivo incluye
a la sociedad civil
estos tres sectores dado que abarcan a
toda la sociedad estamos haciendo algo
para impulsar la innovación
y tercero estamos realmente conscientes
que la innovación nos puede llevar a
mejorar nuestra calidad de vida a
mejorar nuestros países y nuestra región
estamos realmente conscientes de que la
innovación es el factor de cambios del
factor clave de éxito de competitividad
y productividad pues tres preguntas que
guiaron el desarrollo de esta
presentación de las pues de las cuales
voy a hablar el día de hoy y entonces
empecé a indagar algo más y encontré
este dato 23%
de acuerdo al banco interamericano de
desarrollo en uno de los últimos
estudios solamente apenas del 23 por
ciento de latinoamericanos están
conscientes de que la innovación es el
factor clave de éxito y es lo que nos va
a llevar a mejorar nuestros países
nuestras condiciones de vida y en
definitiva nuestra región apenas el 23
por ciento de latinoamericanos y es un
número sumamente bajo resultado de eso
este otro número
de acuerdo a la ompi la organización
mundial de la propiedad intelectual
en su estudio 2019 para determinar el
ranking del índice global de innovación
recién en el puesto 51 de 129 países
aparece el primer país latinoamericano
en el ranking eso es el resultado de que
tan pocas personas 23% en latinoamerica
estén convencidas de que hay que cambiar
para hacer mejores cosas de que la
innovación es el factor clave de éxito
y más aún en el puesto 98 aparece el
ecuador de los mismos de entre los
mismos 129 países estos son los
resultados de esa poca cantidad de gente
que está convencida de la innovación y
que hace innovación
y entonces este es nuestro esquema de lo
que estamos hablando el sector público
el sector productivo y la academia en el
centro ese espacio en rojo que es la
conjunción la combinación la mixtura de
todas esas ideas que se generan en los
tres sectores mientras más grandes de
este espacio en rojo que ustedes ven en
ese esquema pues más importante son las
ideas de innovación que se empiezan a
impulsar y efectivamente son el
resultado de la articulación y de la
interacción de toda la sociedad en su
conjunto sector académico hoy día aquí
presente sector productivo hoy día aquí
presente y seguramente el sector público
hoy día también aquí presente la
sociedad en su conjunto interactuando
para impulsar la innovación siempre y
cuando todos estemos conscientes de que
cambiar
e innovar es el camino del éxito para
ser más productivo más competitivo para
mejorar la calidad de vida pero en
latinoamérica solamente el 23 por ciento
de personas están completamente
convencidos de eso pero quiero dejar un
momento el modelo año recuerden que este
es el modelo vamos a regresar al modelo
en unos minutos más sin embargo el
modelo que impulsa
para qué sirve para impulsar la
innovación pero si no estamos
convencidos de que la innovación es
realmente lo que debemos conseguir como
país y como región pues tenemos
complicaciones hablemos de la innovación
que es la innovación la innovación son
todos esos desarrollos de productos o
servicios o cambios y modificaciones
sustanciales son todos esos desarrollos
de los procesos productivos para
producir esos productos o servicios o
cambios sustanciales la innovación
también es todos esos cambios en los
modelos organizativos y también esos
cambios en los modelos comerciales y
este esquema que ustedes ven ahí es el
que usualmente se lo utiliza para
determinar
y explicar cuál es el modelo de
desarrollo de la innovación el conocido
túnel de innovación en donde ustedes
pueden ver la etapa inicial idea cierto
definición diseño y desarrollo
todos estos desarrollos cuando han sido
introducidos en un contexto social digas
el mercado la innovación suscita
pero antes de las ideas hay un elemento
importantísimo y que es el detonante de
esas ideas porque no es una idea es un
conjunto de ideas combinadas puntos
combinados y es efectivamente impulsa la
innovación pero que impulsa las ideas
que impulsa una o más ideas una
característica fundamental con la que
todos nacemos la creatividad autores
como stephen coa hablan acerca de la
creatividad y justamente señalan que es
una característica innata de todos los
humanos sin embargo conforme van pasando
los años esta característica la vamos
escondiendo cada vez más
y stephen coa señala que hay al menos
tres prácticas tres de actividades que
debemos desarrollar para estimular para
poder expresar esa esa creatividad cada
vez más y poder alcanzar más y mejores
ideas más y mejores ideas y estas tres
actividades y son como cuando uno quiere
tener un bíceps más grande fíjense el
gimnasio para esas las pesas y si haces
una rutina pues donde tener un bíceps
más grande y así toda tu musculatura en
creatividad hay que hacer tres cosas la
primera redes sociales
pero no virtuales no las que tenemos de
nuestras aplicaciones de nuestro
teléfono redes sociales
físicamente presencialmente amigos
contactos más personas conocidas hablar
con más gente con otros familiares de
los que no vemos nunca evidentemente
siempre estamos con nuestro mismo
círculo de pertenencia con los mismos
amigos y con los mismos familiares
porque todos pensamos igual y entonces
para no complicarnos siempre estamos
solo con ellos
qué termina pasando que no accedemos a
más información sino a la información
habitual y a lo que todos decimos y
hacemos porque estamos cómodos y
entonces entramos a la escuela el
colegio la universidad y hacemos dos o
tres amigos y pasamos con ellos el resto
de la vida y nos olvidamos de que hay
más de siete mil millones de personas en
el mundo más de los cuales podríamos
aprender más cosas desarrollen redes
sociales
2 conocimiento y experiencia
es decir conocimiento formal lo que
usted está haciendo aquí o cuando en
otro curso un seminario en la
universidad en el instituto cuando se en
ese conocimiento formal y están
acumulando conocimiento pero eso no es
lo único sino la experiencia la
capacidad que tienen para poder aplicar
ese conocimiento desarrollar la
experiencia aplicando ese conocimiento
es decir asumir los riesgos
y lastimosamente nuestra cultura no está
diseñada para que asumamos los riesgos y
peor aún el fracaso
pero la cultura también se desarrolla se
aprende a ser mejor por lo tanto debemos
aprender a asumir los riesgos los
riesgos los fracasos y superar los
conocimiento y experiencia y tercero
oportunidades estar atentos a las
oportunidades y que nos pasa que nos
levantamos todos los días a la misma
hora vamos a la ducha vamos al desayuno
hacemos todo el apuro al mismo salimos a
la misma hora vamos por el mismo camino
llegamos con los mismos minutos de
atraso a la media mañana tomamos el
mismo café o té con galletas almorzamos
en el mismo lugar hacemos todo lo mismo
al apuro en la tarde salimos a la misma
hora regresamos a la casa por el mismo
camino pasamos comprando el pan la leche
los huevos vemos las redes sociales
antes dormir dormimos y al día siguiente
exactamente lo mismo
365 días del año toda la vida
hay que romper la rutina tres cosas que
hay que hacer
si buscas nuevos resultados si buscas
resultados distintos no sigas haciendo
las mismas cosas
tú dijo stein
weinstein un innovador
por lo tanto se trata de romper ser
disruptivo mal estoy cansado creo que
falta azúcar no te falta romper te falta
ser disruptivo creer que realmente
cambiando e innovando puedes hacer las
cosas mejor es un mejor país una mejor
sociedad una mejor región pero como está
pasando la innovación
rogers señala que las personas nos
dividimos en cinco grupos de acuerdo a
cómo adoptamos la innovación y cómo
adoptamos los proyectos innovadores
cinco grupos los más innovadores que son
los que más rápido adoptan la innovación
los adoptantes tempranos que son los
segundos de adoptar la innovación los
terceros que son la mayoría temprana
mayoría tardía y rezagados pero si a
esto le ponemos valores vamos a ver que
los más innovadores los que más rápido
adoptan la innovación son apenas del 2.5
por ciento luego tenemos un 13.5 por
ciento de los docentes tempranos y el
tercer grupo nos permite llegar al 50
por ciento de toda la población mayoría
temprana 34 por ciento cuando estos tres
grupos han adoptado una innovación una
forma de hacer las cosas
han cambiado el resto de la población el
otro 50% se integra
por eso ese 23 por ciento de
latinoamérica que creen que la
innovación es importante para mejorar no
nos alcanza necesitamos llegar al tercer
grupo de incidencia la mayoría temprana
por eso 23% no nos alcanza y entonces
tenemos que ser parte de este grupo y
tenemos que ir rápido y cada vez más
rápido porque mientras nosotros estamos
pensando que nos están ocurriendo las
mejores ideas de sistemas de 7000
millones de personas pensando en
exactamente lo mismo que nosotros
velocidad más desarrollo aprovechamiento
de las técnicas los mecanismos y los
instrumentos de lo que hoy vivimos y se
llama transformación digital industria
4.0 y quien mueve la industria 4.0 estos
principales grupos de personas que
adoptan la innovación los nuevos modelos
de negocio las nuevas formas de hacer
proyectos y que son a quienes yo
denomino los revolucionarios 4.0 y les
invitó a ser revolucionarios 4.0 pero es
importante ir rápido y cada vez más
rápido velocidad más aceleración muchas
personas están pensando lo mismo que
nosotros el primero en llegar a ese
contexto social para poder resolver
problemas el primero es el que puede
golpear desde el que puede entrar en el
que se puede posicionar
y entonces si tenemos de ese 50 por
ciento de personas se redistribuyen en
nuestro modelo de triple hélice se
distribuyen son 50 por ciento de
personas trabajando el sector público el
sector productivo y el sector académico
y no perdemos porque perderíamos con el
23% porque al ser menos personas las
ideas se distribuyen en los distintos
sectores y al final no se conectan las
personas no trabajan de forma articulada
y no interactúan si es que es un 50% al
menos de gente que está convencida de
que hay que cambiar y de que hay que
innovar al repartirnos de los tres
sectores desde nuestro punto de
influencia sea laboral sea educativo sea
productivo pues empezamos a
interconectar nos empezamos a ver a
conocer y desarrollamos proyectos es por
eso que la interacción es fundamental
pero el primer paso antes de llegar al
modelo
creo que la innovación nos va a ayudar a
cambiar entonces el sector público
desarrolla políticas y desarrolla
incentivos que no necesariamente
impulsan la innovación o si es que los
tienen no lo saben comunicar y el sector
productivo que es el que sabe invertir
no saben qué tecnologías invertir ni
cómo investigar nuevas tecnologías para
invertir la determinación de inversiones
clásicas tradicionales y el sector
académico que tiene la investigación que
tiene rigor que tiene la metodología que
tienen las tecnologías y que tienen los
laboratorios no tiene la plata
porque evidentemente no es una empresa
pero la plata está en el sector
productivo y en el sector privado y si
es que según el sector privado y la
academia pueden investigar y desarrollar
soluciones reales para problemas reales
y el sector público puede premiar esa
articulación y el modelo empieza a
funcionar el primer paso creer realmente
que hay que cambiar y que la inclusión
es fundamental la primera variable a
vencer el tiempo
mientras nosotros estamos discutiendo y
debatiendo de esta temática otros países
han superado este debate y realmente lo
están viviendo y lo están haciendo día a
día
nosotros tenemos que ir rápido y cada
vez más rápido
y lo bueno y la buena noticia de todo
esto
es que a diferencia de las revoluciones
industriales anteriores esta revolución
industrial esta industria 4.0 esta
transformación digital que estamos
viviendo y que nos presta todos los
mecanismos posibles para poder innovar
cambiar y desarrollar mis mejores
proyectos no dependen necesariamente del
acceso a tierras ya grandes bienes de
capital sino de la voluntad de todos
nosotros de aplicar el conocimiento de
generar ideas y de ser cada vez más
creativas
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]